Hi, everyone.
I am really excited to be up here talk to
you about browser extensions.
We are going to talk about what they can do,
challenges my team faced when we built ours,
and most importantly what all this has to
do with sandwiches.
My name is Shannon Capper and I am a front-end
developer here in Seattle as a starting company
called Textio.
I should tell you a little bit about what
I do.
This is Textio.
We are an augmented writing platform that
lets you know how your language is going to
perform as you write it.
We document a score, we use highlights to
draw your attention to key phrases and suggest
replacements for troublesome language.
We are writing a recruiting aid here and as
you can imagine this isn't the ideal user
experience to write e-mail.
It is disruptive to come over to our website
to write the e-mail and copy and paste it
to send it.
Ideally we would want to bring the platform
to you.
We wanted to build something that looks like
this.
This is someone else's page and someone else's
e-mail editor but with all the text in U OOSHGS
that our users know and love -- UI.
What actually is a browser extension?
Out of curiosity, how many of you use browser
extensions on a regular basis?
Basically everyone.
Now how many of you know how to actually build
one?
That is actually a pretty good number.
You may be smarter than me but I use browser
extensions all the time and had no idea how
they worked until I started building one.
It turns out they are pretty straightforward.
A browser extension or a plugin is just a
small piece of software that runs inside the
browser.
My extensions are built with JavaScript, HTML
and CSS.
There is a standardized web extension backed
by the W3C.
Safari and Internet Explorer use different
extensions so it
is difficult with them.
The question you should be asking here is
what can't a browser extension do because
these things are crazy powerful.
Frankly, it is kind of terrifying knowing
all things we are capable of.
For example, you can get lots of controls
over your tabs.
It can open new ones, read the ones open currently,
and close them.
Pop-up blocks for a good example of this.
They monitor open tabs and monitor those that
detect problems.
And we can make network requests.
Mail checker will ping the server regularly
to see if you have new mail and if it detects
new ones it shows you how many.
We can read, modify and add to the DOM of
any web page and this could be used in a creative
way.
This is a video of Google's translate which
reads the selected text from the DOM and adds
a tool set to the page to show you the translation.
Another example is my personal favorite called
millennials to snake people and it is awesome.
What it does is finds any instance of the
word millennials on the page and replaces
it with the word snake people to write results
like this.
Here the plugin is actively modifying text
nodes put into the DOM by the house page and
that could be dangerous but we will get to
that later.
To go back to the earlier question, if browser
extensions can do all those amazing and powerful
things then what can't they do?
The list is pretty small.
First, they are tied to the browser so if
the browser isn't open, the extension can't
run.
Pretty obvious but worth calling out.
Next, you can't go changing your permissions
willy-nilly.
You have to declare which pages you want to
run on and which parts of the web extension
API you want
to access.
If you want to go change those permissions
later on, the extension is temporarily disabled
until the user agrees to the user's new one.
Probably the most important thing it can't
do is directly interact with the
host page's JavaScript.
They don't even share the same Window object.
While this is sometimes a problem, for the
most part, it is a good thing.
At CascadiaJS two years ago, it was called
out the dealing with the polluted objects.
The host page might do bad monkey patching
and the good news is we don't have to deal
with any of that because we are in an isolated
environment.
Under the hood, a browser extension is made
up of four parts.
A manifest file containing metadata and specifies
permission, there is a pop-up which can be
invoked by clicking on the extensions icon
in the browser's toolbar, there is a background
script running behind the scenes whenever
the browser is open and isn't tied to any
one tab and has access to the full web extension
API, then there is the context scripts and
they can talk back and forth with the background
script.
If you are used to seeing server-client architecture
diagrams you will notice this is looking similar.
These are the ones that can interact with
the DOM and what we will focus on for the
rest of the talk.
Let's get back to our story.
My team decided we wanted to build a com extension.
We decided to start with Chrome since that
is what most users use and we knew we could
extend to other browsers.
We wanted to bring Textio to e-mail and supported
clients.
Namely LinkedIn recruiters and Gmail.
Now that we know the powerful things an extension
can do, it should be straightforward to make
this picture a reality, right?
No, it wasn't straightforward at all.
Turns out writing JavaScript that runs on
someone else's page is way harder than writing
JavaScript that runs on your page.
As a browser extension, you have no control
over the page.
You can't control how its laid out, you can't
control the code or the user action and every
single page is different.
Not only that, but it is also super easy to
abuse your power and change things in a way
that brick -- breaking news -- breaks the
host site.
We laid down a set of principles and principle
one is don't write site specific conditionals
and number two is don't break the host page.
Let's start with the first one.
One problem writing an ex tension that works
across multiple hosts is each one is different.
What if you need to tweak the layout based
on the site?
What if you need the selectors to be different
on different pages?
In the early days of the extension, especially
if you start out with a small subset of sites,
it can be tempting to let site-specific conditionals
creep in the database.
If I am on Gmail do A and if I am on LinkedIn
do B.
This is the path to madness.
It will be an absolute nightmare to contain.
Every time you want to support a new site,
you have to track down every place scattered
in the codebase where you have site-specific
logic and that will be no fun.
You might try building solutions in a generic
way so they work on every page.
The key thing here is code reviews.
The more code that is reusable against all
sites, the better.
Where that isn't possible you can try limiting
site specific code to a single configuration
site.
One config per site and all the rest of the
code can generically consume the site config
without worry about the host site.
If you want to add support for a new site
all you have to do is build a single new site
config and you will be good to go.
Let's see this in action, shall we?
I am going to exit out of here and let's mirror
our screen.
OK.
Here we are in Gmail.
I don't know about you guys but there is something
I really miss about writing on my computer.
Something that feels missing.
You know what I miss?
I miss clippy.
I want to build an extension that brings Clippy
back.
We have a content script running in Gmail
and let's see if we can get him into Yahoo.
Let's look at some code.
Here we are on in our code editor.
This is the content script running on Gmail.
It is really simple and just has three parts.
First we will get the site config, next pull
from mail Windows and if we find a new mail
Window, we will append to clippy.
Let's break each one down.
We only support Gmail right now.
This has a single item in it which is our
mail limit selector.
This selector is going to be different on
every site and this gives us the chance to
do the right selector.
Here on guest site config it is simple.
We will get the domain name off the URL, if
it is a supported domain we will return the
equivalent config.
We have a set interval here that is simple.
We will consume that site config and pull
the selector off to hold the DOM to see if
we have new mail Windows.
New one is marked as found and append clippy.
Here in append clip', y we will create image-only,
show the dif, give styling and size and append
him to the mail Window.
I think we will get him working in Yahoo without
too many changes and let's see if we can get
that happening.
Here, let's add Yahoo has a supported domain.
We are going to return a Yahoo config.
Let's define that.
Here we are going to mirror our config from
Gmail.
Then I cheated and looked up what the selector
is so it is going to be editor-container.
That was it.
Let's see if this worked.
I am going to refresh our extension, refresh
the page and I don't have any internet.
That is unfortunate.
Let's connect and try again.
There we go!
We have got Clippy!
[Applause]
>> We kind of have a problem.
He is a little small?
Like in Gmail the mail Window is smaller so
he seems like a good size but here he kind
of gets drowned out.
Let's see if we can use our site config to
fix that.
Let's add site-specific styling.
Down here in append clippy instead of using
the hardcoded value let's assume our site
config and design a clippysizevalue there.
Up here in Gmail let's do clippy size is 85
pixels and over in Yahoo let's make him 120.
Now if everything worked according to plan
it should be a little bit bigger.
Beautiful.
I think we can do one better.
Remember principle number one if we can avoid
site-specific code, we should, because that
way we can keep site configs as small as possible
and make it super easy to add new sites in
the feature.
I think all we want is for clippy to be a
certain percentage of the mail Window size.
Let's do that.
Go back to the Code Editor and remove the
value off site config and down here in append
clippy let's use the mail height dynamic to
determine how big clippy should be.
I will put the height property off there and
that is going to be a string so let's parse
it into a float.
Then let's make clippy three tenths the height
of the mail Window.
If everything went according to plan, he should
be the same size exactly as he was before
but now we are doing it in a dynamic way that
will work on any host site.
Awesome.
[Applause]
>> Let's go back to the slides.
Now we have talked about how to fulfill principle
number one.
Let's talk about principle number two.
Don't break the host page.
This one seems obvious but it is a little
tricky to follow if you are doing anything
adding UI to the page.
Perhaps avoiding the host pages markup might
be a better way to identify it.
Remember we talked about the extension living
in an isolate world, remember the one thing
we share is the DOM.
If we go making changes to the DOM, especially
mutating or deleting stuff that is there,
the host page won't be expecting it because
they don't even know we exist.
Let's use a simple example.
Here is a paragraph rendered by a page.
A paragraph with a little text.
Let's say we as the extension want the highlight
the word hello.
The main think you could try is delete the
text notes in the paragraph and insert a highlight
span containing the word hello and a new text
Node containing the word world but we have
a problem.
It turns out this page was rendered using
React and frameworks like React really don't
like it when you go working with the DOM behind
their back.
It is keeping a virtual representation of
the DOM in memory and still thinks that text
Node is there.
Let's say it goes through another vendor pass
and wants to change the paragraph to say hello,
Seattle.
Best case scenario is that React blows away
the whole paragraph element and replaces it
with a new one.
That is kind of a bummer for us because now
our highlight is gone but worst case scenario
is React just tries to replace that one text
Node, which is no longer there, and it blows
up with a non-failure.
Now we have broken the page and thrown principle
number two out the Window.
This seems bad.
Highlighting text is kind of a core experience
of our product at Textio.
If your Chrome extension can't add inline
spans around the host markup then what are
we supposed to do?
We did like many engineers before us and we
drew notes and eventually we came up with
a different highlight solutions entirely and
that is how the sandwich was born.
Despite it having the stupidest code name
every it is the highlight of the Chrome extension.
It is called the sandwich because it is made
up of layers that are positioned one on top
of each other and gave us fine grain control
of how we edit the page and don't touch the
native editor.
Let's say the text from the native editor
look like this but because this is a rich
text editor users could change the text color
or add background color or maybe change font
sizes.
Let's say we as the extension want to add
highlights to the page.
A green highlight around our team and orange
highlight around connect with you.
For added fun, when you hover over a highlight,
we want to turn the text white.
In the sandwich, the top layer our native
editor.
We want it on top so it picks up all the mouse
and keyboard events like normal and we will
not touch the markup.
We will only make it transparent except for
the cursor.
Directly behind the vendor is our text copy.
This is the exact duplicate of the native
editor with all the background colors hitter.
When you type in editor with the sandwich
mode on it this is the text you will see.
Because we only the copy it is save to modify
and turn hovered text white.
Below that we have colored divs positioned
to sit behind the text they highlight.
The phrases we want to highlight can be calculated
where we want to position these in the DOM.
Last but not least we have the background
color copy.
This is the same as the text copy with the
text colors hidden and background colors visible.
This allows us to draw highlights so they
don't get obscured.
Put it together and you get beautifully highlighted
text in someone else's rich text editor.
We don't have the touch the native markup
and are much less likely to break the page.
Like with most things, our sandwich highlighter
came at a price.
It solved a lot of problems but made new ones.
When I say we made duplicates it turned out
harder to be than I thought.
Making the contents is easy but making the
copy look the same is not.
We used a combination of still overrides to
get them to look right but oh, man, we would
get one pixel differences throwing off the
layout and causing heuristics all in one spot.
Next, we had a problem picking up mouse events
properly.
They don't propagate down to the other layers.
We want you to hover over a phrase and change
the styling.
We implemented our own mouse dropping and
put a listening on the top most element and
from there we can calculate if the mouse is
within the bounds of highlights.
If the mouse moves into a highlight, we can
take it down to the lower layers as if it
happened natively.
This felt like a total hack but we could not
find a better way of getting the mouse events
to hit both layers at once.
We hit snags also getting the layers to be
positioned on top of another.
In order for this to work, we need a parrot
Node positioned as well and remember principle
two we don't want to break the host page and
if we slap a position relative on a parent
Node we risk doing that.
To solve the technology, we pulled in an intelligent
called the shadow dom.
I will be brief about why this helped us.
Let's say this is a piece of the DOM we got
from our host page and this is called the
light DOM as opposed to shadow DOM.
We made a parent Node with a child note.
The shadow DOM lets us attach a subtree that
is hidden from the main application.
Within that subtree we can render a div with
position relative and from there we can drop
in our original child Node.
This is using the slot API which lets you
insert like-DOM shadow hosts into the shadow
tree.
Now we can add the sandwich layers as siblings.
This is great.
To the application, the DOM tree thinks the
native editor is a direct child of the shadow
host but what is rendered to the passenger
is -- page is that and we can render till
our hearts desire.
How did it work out?
Was our Chrome extension a success?
I probably wouldn't be here talking to you
if it wasn't so let me show you.
I am going to mirror my screen again and let's
come over here.
So, here we are in Gmail again.
Now we are writing a recruiting mail.
Let's turn on Textio for Chrome.
Boom!
Beautifully highlighted text in someone's
editor.
We have highlights in the subject line and
body and we have a score.
An orange phrase means this is causing less
people to respond to my recruiting mail.
Let's replace that and now it is green meaning
it will attract people and the score updated.
We can type in real-time and update.
If I say wow, this is great.
Not only do highlights show up in the text
I just typed but the ones there move over.
Then, because this is a rich text editor,
let's do terrible things like making the font
big and adding some text color.
All of it just kind of works.
Because we wrote this not as a Gmail editor
but a highlight editor it also works in LinkedIn.
Here we are recruiting our fantastic host
and you will notice it is the same experience
here as it was in Gmail.
We are happy because we are not texting the
native editor's markup' and less likely to
break a page and this is extensible and we
can drop it into any editor and it will work.
We are using the site configs and it is easy
to expand out as Textio grows into other domains.
Let's wrap this up.
OK.
If there is anything I want you guys to get
out of this talk it is these three things.
Besides sick memes, obviously.
A browser extension is an incredibly powerful
tool and really the only limit to what you
can accomplish with them is your imagination.
Two, writing code that runs on someone else's
site is an adjustment.
It is a mental shift in show you approach
problems and there is going to be a mess of
challenges.
Keep the principles in mind and avoid site
specific code and don't break someone else's
page.
Trust me you will thank yourself later.
That is it for me.
I hope you are all inspired to build extensions
after today.
There is good information and the slides from
today.
If you have questions, find me here, or online.
I would tell you you could find me on Twitter
but that would be a lie because I don't have
one so e-mail or GitHub works great.
Thank you so much, everyone, and happy building.